.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vielleicht rettet Ihnen einer
dieser jungen Menschen mal das Leben.
Sie sind
angehende Pflegefachkräfte ...
... oder Rettungssanitäterinnen.
Die Ausbildung ist streng, der Beruf
spannend, aber anspruchsvoll.
Rebecca, Fanny ...
... Hélène und Lucas
wollen in einer Branche arbeiten,
die viele andere verlassen.
Warum - das erzählt diese Serie.
In Aigle ist Pizzapause
für die Studierenden aller
Rettungsdienste der Westschweiz.
Sie haben
ihren letzten praktischen Übungstag.
Hier treffen wir
die 25-jährige Fribourgerin Fanny.
Ich wollte als Kind
Polizistin werden.
Mein Götti war Sanitäter
und bot mir ein Praktikum an.
Dort nahm es mir den Ärmel rein.
"Das ist es", dachte ich.
"Ich will Sanitäterin werden."
Heute geht es um einen Autounfall.
(Frau) Hört zu: Das Auto brennt,
und die Person muss so schnell
wie möglich rausgeholt werden.
Eine Hand muss vorne beim Kopf sein.
- (Frau) So geht es nicht.
Warte.
So, oder am Gurt halten,
wenn das geht. Wir versuchen es.
* Ächzen *
Ah, mir wird schlecht.
Die Übungen laufen bestens.
Auch weil sich
die Studierenden gut verstehen.
In den Gesundheitsberufen
kommt man sich sehr nahe.
Das sieht man bei den Übungen.
Man muss sich berühren,
um das zu lernen.
Es geht nicht anders.
Manchmal fühlt man sich
etwas unwohl.
Aber das vergeht schnell.
- So kann man jede Person rausholen.
Er ist aber viel schwerer als ich.
- Ja.
Viel schwerer.
Vertraust du mir? Okay.
- Ja.
Oh, das geht tatsächlich.
Und jetzt ... so ...
(Frau) Dann legst du ihn langsam ...
Den Kopf halten.
Genau.
Das war gar nicht so schwer.
- Es ist eine Frage der Technik.
Du kannst ihn auch am Gurt heben.
- Ja.
Je nach Bekleidung. Bei einem
Sommerkleid geht das nicht.
Oder an der Unterhose.
Die Stimmung ist gut.
Wir lachen viel,
sind aber immer konzentriert.
Jetzt geht es
um einen grösseren Unfall,
bei dem es zwei Feuerwehr- und
vier Krankenwagen vor Ort braucht.
Wenn alle mitmachen, auch die Feuer-
wehr - die Polizei fehlte zwar -,
ist es manchmal einfacher,
einzugreifen.
Die Autos liegen auf dem Dach.
Die Verunfallten
werden von Lernenden gespielt.
Wir fangen an.
Die Ambulanz, 144,
meldet den Verkehrsunfall -
im Jargon "VU".
Wir haben einen VU mit drei Autos
und mehreren Insassen.
Wir brauchen Unterstützung.
Das Adrenalin stieg bei uns allen.
Alle waren sich im Klaren,
dass sie wirklich Gas geben mussten.
Sind Sie eingeklemmt?
Kann der Kollege hinten sprechen?
Alles gut bei Ihnen am Steuer?
- Mit den Beinen stimmt ...
Das erste Rettungsteam vor Ort
macht eine Triage.
Können Sie atmen?
Das hilft dabei zu wissen,
wer welche Betreuung braucht:
grün für Leichtverletzte, rot für
Notfälle und schwarz für Todesopfer.
Wie viele sind da drin?
- Rot, gelb und grün für B.
Alles okay bei Ihnen?
- Jetzt kommen Fanny und ihr Kollege.
Grüezi. Wir kümmern uns um Sie.
Okay?
Oh nein. Ich mache das gerade.
Die Autotür klemmt.
Die Fahrerin hat Bauchverletzungen.
Ein lebensbedrohlicher Notfall.
Man musste sie schnell rausholen.
Es war schwierig, weil wir
gar nicht richtig an sie rankamen.
Wir konnten sie nicht berühren,
um sie so zu beruhigen.
Wer ist die Person neben Ihnen?
- Mein Freund.
Okay, Ihr Freund. Geht es ihm gut?
- Nein, er blutet.
Fliesst viel Blut?
Der Kopf ist nach hinten geknickt.
Die Feuerwehr
muss das Dach abnehmen.
Dann schauen wir,
wie es Ihrem Freund geht. Okay?
Fanny muss die Feuerwehr
um Hilfe bitten.
Aber sie zögert.
- Wie viel Zeit haben wir?
Die Instruktorin notiert jede Geste.
Könnten wir
durch die Windschutzscheibe?
Wenn es 10 Min. geht ...
- 1 Min.
Ah, 1 Min?
- Ich mache das sofort.
Okay.
Wir können uns vorbereiten.
Kümmerst du dich um die Patientin?
- Ich gehe zu ihr.
Ich kümmere mich ums Material.
- Gerne.
Am besten schneidest du da durch.
So sind wir schneller.- Hier?
Wir schneiden
die Windschutzscheibe auf.
Schützen Sie Ihr Gesicht
und schliessen Sie Augen und Mund.
Den Kopf vorne runterhalten.
Kopf runter.
Es passiert Ihnen nichts.
Valeria will sich schützen
und verlangt eine Decke.
Aber niemand hört sie.
Die Säge ist falsch positioniert
und das Glas
zerspringt in tausend Scherben.
Sie schnitten die obere Scheibe
anstatt der Windschutzscheibe auf.
Darum zersplitterte das Glas und
fiel auf die ungeschützte Patientin.
Man sah,
dass die Säge falsch angesetzt war.
Man hätte reagieren können.
Aber ich vergass, sie zu schützen.
Das kann auch
bei einem realen Unfall passieren.
Mach ein Loch rein.- Warte,
das fällt alles auf die beiden.
Fanny hat gerade erfahren,
dass auch die Feuerwehrleute
noch in Ausbildung sind.
Valeria, schütz dich gut.
Okay.
Die Glassplitter haben sie verletzt.
Die Instruktoren brechen die Übung
ab, bis Valeria geschützt ist.
Ja, sie blutet.
- Wir hören auf.
Sonst wird es noch schlimmer.
- Okay.
Valeria wird zugedeckt,
damit die Schnittverletzungen
nicht schlimmer werden.
Endlich
ist die Windschutzscheibe draussen,
und Fanny kann sich
um den zweiten Verletzten kümmern.
Er lebt nicht mehr.
Wir machen das so ...
Lucas,
der Patient daneben ist tot.
Es braucht
eine schwarze Bezeichnung.
Die Feuerwehrleute müssen das Dach
mit einer riesigen Schneidezange
aufreissen.
Achtung, Nico, deine Finger.
Man musste das Dach aufreissen,
um sie rauszuholen.
Sie konnte wegen all der Scherben
gar nicht aufstehen.
Wir mussten sie
sorgfältig rausheben,
damit sie sich
nicht noch mehr verletzt.
Ja.
So. Perfekt.
Fanny braucht einen Moment,
um alles zu verarbeiten.
Ich habe nicht daran gedacht,
sie zu schützen.
Das war nicht unsere Aufgabe.
Wir wollten die Windschutzscheibe,
nicht die obere, aufschneiden.
Ich sah nicht,
dass alles auf sie fallen könnte.
Es war nicht der Plan,
dort aufzuschneiden.
Wir nützen gerade gar nichts. Es ist
frustrierend, warten zu müssen.
Äh, ja ... warten.
Die andere Gruppe macht weiter
und birgt die Verletzten.
Man muss sie rausholen
und Erste Hilfe leisten.
Zum Glück habe ich
eine Notfallbergung angefragt.
Okay.
Es ging 10 Min.,
bis das Autodach endlich nachgab.
Okay.
Sie kann raus, oder? Es ist gut?
Der Abtransport der Kollegin
ist eine knifflige Angelegenheit.
Ich halte den Kopf.
Sie ist voller Glassplitter.
Gut, es geht los.
- Wir müssen ganz langsam machen.
Wir müssen sie
ganz langsam rausnehmen.
Also, Valeria,
du blutest ein bisschen.
Geht es? Leg den Kopf hin.
Sorgfältig. Eins, zwei, drei.
- Sehr gut.
Achtung,
sie hat überall Glassplitter.
Langsam ablegen.
- Mhm.
Okay.
Sollen wir helfen?
- Super.
So.
Jetzt muss sie
die Plastikpuppe fixieren,
dann ist die Übung
für Fanny abgeschlossen.
Fahren wir ihn ins CHUV?
Wir müssen den Chef
des Rettungsdienstes fragen.
Chefrettungssanitäter von AZUR 02,
antworten.
Der Verletzte ist auf einer Bahre
fixiert und kommt ins Spital.
Wir bringen ihn
mit dem AK5 ins CHUV, antworten.
Die Übung ist nach einer
knappen Stunde abgeschlossen.
Fanny schaut, wie es Valeria geht.
Geht es? Tut mir wirklich leid.
Ich habe nicht realisiert,
dass sie das Fenster kaputtmachen.
Ich hatte keine orange Weste.
Aber die hätte mir
auch nicht geholfen.
Es war alles voller Scherben.
Ich wollte mich
einfach nicht bewegen.
Ich hatte überall Splitter.
- Klar.
Darum ging ich duschen.
- Aber geht es?
Klar.
Nein ...
Man sieht es ein bisschen.
- Was genau machen die?
Immerhin besser,
dass das jetzt schon passiert ist.
Aus Fehlern lernt man.
Die Stimmung unter
den Studierenden des Rettungsdienstes
hat sich wieder aufgeheitert.
Rechtzeitig für das Foto.
(Mann)
Das gibt ein Foto für den Kalender.
Ja. Schade, wenn du morgen nicht
mehr zur Schule kommen könntest.
Nach der dreijährigen Ausbildung
gehen sie bald getrennte Wege.
(Mann) Wir nehmen die Masken ab.
Eins, zwei, drei, weg damit.
Kurz nicht atmen.
Okay.
Morgenstimmung im Ausbildungszentrum
der Lausanner Klink La Source.
In der Cafeteria treffen wir Hélène.
Was nicht gegessen wird,
geht später weg.
Sie ist 21 und im dritten Jahr
der Ausbildung zur Pflegefachfrau.
Eigentlich
wollte ich Tierärztin werden.
Aber dann erlebte ich mit,
wie man ein Tier einschläfert -
mit seinem schluchzenden Halter
daneben.
Wir haben ihm nicht mal
ein Taschentuch angeboten
und kümmerten uns nur um das Tier.
Da machte es bei mir klick.
Ich konnte das nicht.
Ich mag Tiere, aber Menschen auch.
Jetzt habe ich einen Beruf,
der mit Menschen zu tun hat.
Ein Herzensberuf,
der zu Hélènes Wesen passt.
Genau.
Ich war schon immer die,
die sich um andere kümmerte,
gerne zuhörte
und andere unterstützte.
Ich gehe in dem Beruf auf.
In der Familie
oder auch unter Freunden -
diese Sensibilität gehört zu mir.
Auf jemanden
zugehen und eingehen zu können -
ich glaube, das ist das,
was ich in meinem Beruf geben kann.
Da kann ich einfach ich selbst sein.
Die Klinik La Source
ist die älteste säkulare
Krankenpflegeschule der Welt.
Nach drei Jahren Ausbildung,
inkl. Spitalpraktikum,
schliessen 1'000 Studierende
mit einem Bachelor ab.
Wir gehen alles normal durch
und führen im nachgestellten
Spitalalltag die Behandlung durch.
Heute geht es
um praktische Übungen für die,
die im letzten Ausbildungsjahr sind.
Im Schuluntergeschoss
haben sich zehn Patientinnen
und Patienten bereitgemacht.
Niemand ist wirklich krank -
sie spielen eine Rolle.
Daniel mimt einen Alzheimerpatienten.
* Langer Piepston *
Hallo?
Genau wie im richtigen Spitalalltag
treffen sich morgens
alle zur Besprechung.
Herr Solis in Zimmer 4 war
in der Nacht ziemlich verängstigt.
Er klingelte immer wieder.
Hélène hört zu, was ihre Kollegin
von der Nachtschicht rapportiert.
Sie macht sich grosse Sorgen
um ihre Gesundheit.
Das rechte Bein beschäftigt sie.
Das Thema Amputation kam auf.
Wir haben zusammen gesprochen.
Sie spricht von Amputation.
Die Ausbildnerinnen machen sich
Notizen von allen Schülerinnen.
Dann geht es in die Spitalapotheke,
wo die Medikamente und das Material
vorbereitet werden.
Hast du da Vitamin B3?
- Schon klingelt der Alarm.
* Regelmässiger Piepston *
Hast du gesehen, wohin sie ging?
Nein, das ist kein Problem.
- Ich komme gleich.
Es ist Herr Solis.
Der Alzheimerpatient
sitzt auf dem Bett seiner Nachbarin.
Das ist nicht Ihre Frau.
Sie ist nicht hier.
Wir können sie anrufen, okay?
Stützen Sie sich hier ab,
dann geht es besser.
Genau.
- Was habe ich gemacht?
Sie sind im Spital.
- Nein.
Ich will nach Hause.
Ich muss vieles erledigen.
Ich will nicht eingesperrt sein.
- Es ist ja gestellt,
aber sie spielen ihre Rolle
so extrem gut.
Wir fragen sie dasselbe
wie echte Patienten.
Und sie reagieren
sehr realistisch auf die Situation.
Grüezi, Herr Solis.
Ich bin Hélène Fontaine
und helfe meiner Kollegin.
Ich hänge Ihre Infusion auf.
An dem Baum, wie eine Dekoration.
Aber wie soll ich
damit fischen gehen?
Heute können Sie nicht fischen.
Ich habe es François versprochen.
Da müssen wir schauen.
Sie sind im Spital.
Sie sind aber stur.
Während Maël versucht,
Herrn Solis zu beruhigen,
kümmert sich Hélène
um eine Diabetikerin,
die ein Geschwür am Fuss hat.
Grüezi.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Mir ist übel, ich habe
Bauchschmerzen und mag nichts essen.
Es ist wirklich ...
Gut, sagen Sie mir einfach
im Verlauf des Morgens,
wenn Sie Hunger kriegen
und essen möchten.
Es ist wichtig, zu essen.
Ich messe trotzdem
den Blutzuckerspiegel.
Soll ich es in echt machen?
Nicht, oder?- Nein.
Klar frage ich die Person,
die die Patientin spielt,
ob ich tatsächlich reinstechen soll
oder lieber nicht.
Man muss ja wissen, wie weit man
bei der Übung gehen kann.
Ich steche jetzt.
Mein Mann
hat im Internet recherchiert
und meinte,
ich könne mein Bein verlieren.
Haben Sie wohl deswegen Bauch-
schmerzen, weil Sie das stresst?
Es geht mir nicht gut.
Ich habe Angst, es zu verlieren.
Es ist verständlich,
dass Sie so reagieren.
Sie spielen alle so gut, dass man
wirklich reinfällt und denkt,
es sei eine echte Situation.
Der improvisierte Spitalalltag
läuft auf Hochtouren.
Meine Kollegin kommt gleich.
Setzen Sie sich doch dorthin.
Prima. Geben Sie mir Ihre Hand.
Im echten Spitalalltag
betreuen die Pflegeleute
sechs bis acht Patienten.
Hier betreuen sie zwei -
und das ist schon genug.
Perfekt.
V.a. mit Alzheimerkranken,
die nie dort bleiben, wo sie sollten.
In so einem Fall
müssen alle wissen, wer Demenz hat
und ein Auge
auf den Patienten haben,
wenn er oder sie
in den Gängen rumspaziert.
Ich muss extrem aufpassen,
dass nichts schiefgeht,
auch wenn ich
gerade etwas anderes mache.
* Spannende Musik *
Schon zu spät:
Herr Solis ist nicht mehr nüchtern
für seine Untersuchungen.
Unmöglich.
Das ist einfach unmöglich.
Es ist 10.30 Uhr.
Zeit für die Arztvisite.
Heute mit einem Arzt,
der es sehr genau nimmt.
Wenn das Gelenk betroffen ist,
ist es mehr als das.
Hélène erklärt, dass ihre Patientin
Angst vor einer Amputation hat.
Weiss man,
ob es zu einer Amputation kommt?
Ich sage mal: nicht sofort.
Aber das kann irgendwann passieren.
1'000 ml Glucosalin für 24 Std.?
- Sie isst und trinkt doch.
Eigentlich isst sie nicht
und hat immer weniger Hunger.
Warum braucht sie Glucosalin?
Weil der Kollege der Nachtschicht
am liebsten 1 l von allem gibt?
Genau.
Draussen auf dem Gang
nützt Herr Solis den Moment aus
und verschwindet heimlich
aus dem Zimmer.
Danke vielmals.
- Danke.- Danke euch.
Es ist Mittag,
und die Übung ist fertig.
Die Schauspielerinnen
und Schauspieler
berichten der Ausbildnerin
von ihren Eindrücken.
Wie haben Sie
den heutigen Morgen erlebt?
(Frau) Sie war sehr freundlich
und unterstützte mich.
Sie hat mir zugehört.
Ich fühlte mich schlussendlich
besser verstanden.
Doch, das war gut.
Ich werde sehr gut betreut.
Sie sind sehr sanft,
aber auch konsequent.
Sie können auf Bedürfnisse eingehen,
beziehen aber auch
ihre Kolleginnen mit ein.
Ich denke, sie waren ein gutes Team.
Dr. Garcia beurteilt, wie
die Studierenden gearbeitet haben.
Ihr wisst viel.
Ich weiss, dass ich euch
herausfordere. So bin ich.
Aber wenn man etwas überlegen muss,
bleibt es einem besser.
Man merkt,
dass eine Überlegung dahintersteckt
und dass ihr eine gute Basis habt
und logisch denkt.
Es war wirklich gut. Bravo.
Eure gute Stimmung
und euer Lächeln ...
Nein, wirklich,
das ist extrem wichtig.
Man sieht und spürt das
auch mit der Maske.
In unserem Beruf
hat man mit kranken Leuten zu tun.
Bei den einen
ist es nichts Schlimmes,
aber es gibt auch Schwerkranke
mit Krebs
oder anderen schweren Krankheiten.
Das macht es
psychologisch nicht einfach.
Wenn man trotzdem mit einer gewissen
Leichtigkeit und einem Lächeln
auf die Patienten zugeht,
kann man besser arbeiten.
Eine gute Stimmung bringt mehr
als Mitleid oder schlechte Laune.
Die Ausbildnerin und der Arzt
waren zufrieden.
Dann glauben wir ihnen das.
Das können wir uns zu Herzen nehmen
und sagen,
dass wir uns vertrauen können.
Ich weiss nicht mehr, was sagen.
Hélène ist erleichtert
über die guten Beurteilungen
und freut sich
aufs verdiente Wochenende.
Aber nicht alle
haben ein freies Wochenende.
Es ist Samstagmorgen,
und wir treffen in Genf
eine andere künftige Pflegefachfrau.
Rebecca trägt aber keine weisse,
sondern eine gelbe Bluse.
Super, danke.
- Danke Ihnen.
Rebecca
arbeitet jeden Samstag in der Post,
um die Ausbildung zu finanzieren.
Auf den roten Knopf drücken.
Rosso. Rouge.
Genau.
Ich komme ganz alleine
für mein Leben auf.
Da muss man als Studentin schauen,
dass man die Miete,
die Rechnungen usw. zahlen kann.
Ja, es ist kompliziert.
Rebecca ist immer gut gelaunt
und dynamisch.
Aber sie hatte es
nicht immer einfach.
Als Jugendliche hatte sie
einen Freund, der sie schlug,
und ihre Mutter
ist an Krebs gestorben.
Wer es zuerst findet, gewinnt.
Eine Geschichte, die auch Rebeccas
Chefin sehr beschäftigt hat.
Ich sah damals eine junge Frau ...
... die arbeiten wollte.
Sie gab sich Mühe,
war aber etwas verloren.
In meinem Leben ist schon zu viel
passiert. Ich mochte nicht mehr.
Ich hätte nicht nur die Lehre
hingeworfen, sondern mein Leben.
Es war sehr schwer.
Es hätte auch schlecht gehen können.
Aber sie hat es geschafft.
Ganz alleine.- Aber ihr wart
eine enorme Unterstützung.
Wir haben dich unterstützt,
aber du hast es gepackt.
Du kannst stolz auf dich sein.
Das werde ich immer wieder sagen.
Nach sechs Jahren bei der Post
wollte Rebecca etwas ganz Neues.
210 Fr., 215 Fr.
Mit ca. 25 oder 24 dachte ich,
dass ich es jetzt machen müsse.
So landete ich
in der Krankenpflegeschule.
Danke. Schönen Tag.
Ich kann nicht jeden Tag aufstehen
und denken "Ich mag nicht"
oder "Ich habe keine Lust".
Ich muss etwas machen,
das mir gefällt.
Es ist Montagmorgen.
Wir treffen Rebecca
im Genfer Universitätsspital,
wo sie ihr letztes Praktikum macht.
Entschuldigen Sie,
wenn ich nicht so viel rede,
ich bin voll konzentriert.
- Macht nichts.
So lerne ich was,
sollte ich eine Umschulung brauchen.
Dafür ist es zwar etwas spät.
- Ja.
Ich entferne gleich den Verband.
Jean-Pierre
hatte einen grossen Bauchdeckenbruch
und wurde operiert.
- Es sind 49 Klammern.
Ein junger Typ sagte mir das.
Ich habe sie nachgezählt,
aber das stimmte nicht.
Eine grosse Narbe, oder?
- Mhm. Aber eine schöne.
In der Abteilung Viszeralchirurgie
lernt Rebecca
nochmals alle technischen Handgriffe.
Ein einziger kleiner Fehler
könnte enorme Folgen haben.
Darum ist Lois, eine diplomierte
Pflegefachfrau, immer dabei.
Wenn ich alleine
zu meinen Patienten gehe,
fühle ich mich wohler.
Ich bin zwar nicht anders als sonst,
wenn sie dabei ist,
aber irgendwie
trotzdem etwas blockiert.
Ich bin nicht entspannt
und überlege die ganze Zeit,
ob ich es wohl richtig mache.
Aber ich bin ja noch in der
Ausbildung, und es ist normal,
dass eine diplomierte Pflegefachfrau
mich begleitet.
Wir machen es wie letztes Mal.
Das hat man sicher erklärt.
Nein.
Ich erkläre es sowieso nochmals.
- Ja, stimmt.
Tief einatmen.
- Genau.
Genau. Dann den Atem anhalten,
und ich nehme den Schlauch raus.
Okay.
- Okay?
Rebecca
muss die Bauchdrainage entfernen.
Eine heikle Sache.
Und nicht einfach,
wenn jemand genau zuschaut.
Nein.
- Gut, perfekt.
Brauchst du keine Kompresse?
- Oh, Entschuldigung.
Nochmals ausatmen. Ja, klar.
- Mhm.
Es gehört eine drunter,
damit es nicht runterfliesst.
Genau.
- Okay. Also, nochmals.
Sehr gut.
Alles gut?
Okay?
- Nein.
Sie haben recht.
Und links. Links noch.
- Hm?
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe recht.
Und links habe ich auch.
Völlig konzentriert auf das,
was sie macht,
versteht Rebecca Jean-Pierres Witze
nicht immer sofort.
Ich witzle manchmal mit ihr.
In meinem Alter darf ich das.
Eine Floskel oder ein Witz -
kein Problem.
So, fertig.
Danke.
- Gerne.
Rebecca ist wieder entspannt.
Überprüfen Sie mich jetzt noch?
Jetzt messe ich noch den Blutzucker.
- Nein, nein.
Nein.
Der Arzt sagte,
das brauche es nicht.
Gut.
Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Ich war etwas überrascht.
Aber was soll ich sagen?
Entschuldigung.
- Sie dürfen Nein sagen.
Ich wollte keine Blutzuckermessung.
Dafür wird mir dreimal pro Tag
in den Finger gestochen.
Das Resultat bleibt immer gleich.
Der Arzt meinte,
das brauche es nicht.
Warum machen, wenn es nichts bringt?
Also.
Ich kontrolliere
aber noch den Venenzugang.
Der Beruf ist nicht immer einfach,
wenn man noch in der Ausbildung ist
und dazu noch jung.
Die älteren Fachleute
haben mehr Erfahrung
und wissen eher, wie man Patienten
motivieren und überzeugen kann,
etwas zuzulassen, das ihnen guttut.
Mir gelingt das nicht immer.
Dann lasse ich es halt.
Vielleicht ist das falsch,
aber wir können ja nichts befehlen.
Es ist wichtig, nicht zu vergessen,
dass die Patienten
das Entscheidungsrecht haben.
Wir dürfen
das nicht einfach übernehmen.
Grüezi. Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Ganz gut.
Haben Sie noch Schmerzen?
Nein.
- Gut. Dann messe ich den Blutdruck.
Thierry liess sich
einen Magenbypass machen.
Ein Meilenstein
im Leben des Gemeindegärtners.
Ich bin übergewichtig.
Ich habe Diabetes
und hohen Blutdruck.
Das ist der einzige Weg,
um Gewicht zu verlieren.
129. Perfekt.
Das klingt doch gut.
Thierry hört ganz genau zu.
Er hofft, heute aus dem Spital
entlassen zu werden.
9,9, das ist gut.
Eine kleine Haarentfernung.
Und noch gratis.
- Nicht wahr?
So, jetzt haben wir es.
Drücken Sie bitte drauf.- Okay.
Alle Resultate sind gut.
Das bedeutet für Thierry:
grünes Licht für die Entlassung.
Rebecca kontrolliert
alle Austrittspapiere mit ihm.
Hier ist das Arztzeugnis.
- Gut.
Und das ist das Rezept.
Das Clexane spritzt Ihnen Ihre Frau,
richtig?- Genau.
Perfekt.
Wenn ich zum Arzt gehe,
sage ich manchmal auch: "Ja, okay."
Aber ich habe
nur die Hälfte verstanden.
Es ist unsere Aufgabe, alles genau
mit dem Patienten durchzugehen.
Um sicherzugehen, dass alles
klar ist und sie wissen, was machen.
Bei einem Magenbypasspatienten
geht es v.a. um die Ernährung
und die Medikamente.
Haben Sie sich schon organisiert?
Um welche Uhrzeit
gehen Sie ungefähr?
Nein, ich muss zuerst noch anrufen.
Aber ...
... ich denke, Anfang Nachmittag.
So um 14 Uhr.
Sehr gut.
- Hier sind Ihre Papiere.
Danke vielmals. Auf Wiedersehen.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Ich bin zufrieden mit dem Resultat.
Es ist wie ein zweites Leben.
Ja.
Die Pflege und alle anderen
sind sehr freundlich.
Ich wurde wirklich unterstützt.
Zum Glück haben wir solche Leute.
Ohne sie ginge es nicht.
Anerkennende Worte
für die Pflegefachleute.
Aber die haben keine Zeit dafür.
Rebecca ist schon wieder unterwegs
auf ihrem Marathon durch die Gänge.
Hallo.
Ich bin mir gewohnt,
unter Zeitdruck zu funktionieren.
Es gefällt mir, wenn etwas los ist
und man tausend Dinge tun muss.
Das mag ich.
Vielleicht bin ich schräg.
Aber ja, so funktioniere ich.
Ich mag es so.
Lucas ist unterwegs
zum Genfer Spital Trois-Chêne.
Der 23-Jährige
macht dort ein letztes Praktikum
in der geriatrischen Notfallstation.
Dass er Krankenpfleger wird,
war für ihn immer klar.
Ich hatte immer schon -
kein Bedürfnis, aber viel Lust ...
... zu helfen oder da zu sein,
wenn jemand meine Hilfe brauchte.
Also.
Als ich allen sagte, dass ich mit
der Krankenpflegeschule weitermache,
war niemand überrascht.
Man hat mir immer gesagt,
ich wäre ein guter Pflegefachmann.
* Sie lacht. *
Wer in der Krankenpflege arbeitet,
muss Menschen wirklich gerne haben
und auf sie zugehen können.
Das kann ich zum Glück gut.
Ich bringe Ihnen das Frühstück.
Die Covid-Patientin Rose-Marie
ist im Spital,
weil sie so extrem müde ist.
Lucas kontrolliert
zusammen mit dem Hilfspfleger,
dass sie gut gebettet ist.
Und er lernt auch noch
etwas über das Spitalbett.
Nur die Rückenlehne runterlassen.
Genau, dort auf den Knopf drücken.
Ich war zu schnell.
- Ja.
Hoppla.
Geht es?
- Machen Sie mich nicht kaputt.
Ups. Ich versuche es nochmals.
Du könntest
auch einfach das Bett runterfahren.
Ja, das wäre einfacher.
So. Jetzt hat es Platz.
Ist gut so?
- Ja.
Wir lassen Sie jetzt
in Ruhe frühstücken.
Wir kommen später nochmals. Ist gut?
Ja.
- Gut.
(Frau) Der Herr
kommt aus einem anderen Spital.
Die Pflegefachleute
informieren sich im Büro,
wer alles neu eingetreten ist.
* Rumpeln *
Meine Kollegin von der Nachtschicht
rannte plötzlich in den Gang raus.
Ich dachte: Da ist etwas nicht gut.
Madame, hallo?
- Ich ging dann auch raus
und sah eine Frau,
die der Länge nach im Gang lag.
Sie war offensichtlich gestürzt.
Rose-Marie
wollte zur Toilette und stürzte.
Bleiben Sie ruhig,
die beiden Männer helfen Ihnen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
- Perfekt.
Lucas hat zwar alles über
solche Notfallsituationen gelernt,
ist aber gerade etwas verloren.
Yamina hilft ihm.
Rausfinden,
ob es etwas mit dem Hirn zu tun hat.
Von Kopf bis Fuss
alles durchchecken.- Okay.
Eine Kopf-bis-Fuss-Untersuchung
heisst,
alle lebenswichtigen Werte
zu kontrollieren:
Puls, Blutdruck,
Sättigung und Blutzucker.
Es ist immer etwas stressig,
weil man nicht weiss,
warum jemand gestürzt ist.
Ist etwas am Kopf passiert,
oder gaben die Beine nach?
Oder ist es etwas noch Schlimmeres?
Ist der Blutdruck zusammengefallen,
war es ein epileptischer Anfall
oder eine Bewusstlosigkeit?
Geht es?
Sie hatten sicher Angst.
Können Sie uns sagen,
was passiert ist?
Ich ging bis zur Schwelle
und verlor das Gleichgewicht.
Ganz plötzlich
verlor ich mein Gleichgewicht.
Das ist mir
vor Längerem mal passiert.
Dann eine Weile nicht mehr.
Und plötzlich fing das wieder an.
Ist der Kopf
auf dem Boden aufgeprallt?- Nein.
Nicht?
In ca. 20 Min. ist Arztvisite.
Dann können wir entscheiden,
was wir am besten für Sie machen.
V.a., damit es Ihnen wieder besser
geht und Sie nicht nochmals stürzen.
Ist das gut?
Nein. Ich möchte
mit meinen Kindern sprechen.
Wer weiss, wie es ihnen geht.
Das ist eine Katastrophe für sie.
- Ja.
Rose-Marie weiss seit dem Morgen,
dass sie Covid hat.
Sie macht sich
v.a. Sorgen um ihre Kinder,
weil die in Quarantäne müssen.
Meine Söhne hätten sich
nächste Woche impfen können.
Aber das geht jetzt ja nicht.
Denken Sie, sie müssen
die 15 Tage zu Hause bleiben?
Machen Sie sich
keine Sorgen deswegen.
Im Moment
geht es um Ihre Gesundheit.
Wir mussten ihr immer wieder sagen,
sie müsse sich keine Sorgen machen,
und dass wir
die ganze Familie informiert hätten.
Und falls sie testen müssten,
würden sie das machen.
Sie sei ja älter und fragiler,
darum gehe es jetzt erst um sie.
Man musste ihr klarmachen,
dass es in erster Linie
um ihre Gesundheit gehe.
Ich komme später nochmals vorbei.
- Gut.
Ich bin in der Nähe.
Danke vielmals.
- Gerne.
Ich komme gleich.
Es ist Zeit für die Arztvisite.
(Frau) Die Frau ist 85 ...
Lucas hatte nur kurz Zeit,
um sich vorzubereiten.
Er konzentriert sich auf
seine Notizen und ist etwas nervös.
Weitere Infos?
Heute Morgen um ca. 7.10 Uhr
stürzte die Frau.
Sie wollte auf die Toilette.
Jetzt schmerzt die Hüfte.
Glasgow-Skala 15,
und die Augen reagieren.
Warst du dabei, als sie stürzte?
- Im Moment selber nicht.
Wir hatten gerade Übergabe.
Aber die Kollegin der Nachtschicht
sah sie am Boden und ging hin.
Und sonst?
- Sorgen wegen ihrer Familie.
Man muss sie etwas runterholen.
Ja.
Sie hat Angst, ihre ganze Familie
mit dem Virus angesteckt zu haben.
Oder umgekehrt.
- Ja.
Aber sie ist
total ängstlich deswegen.
Das war es. Vielen Dank.
Lucas hat es gut gemeistert.
Aber eine Arztvisite
ist für alle Studierenden
immer eine Herausforderung.
Es gibt manchmal Fragen,
mit denen man nicht rechnet.
Dann denkt man: "Mist,
darauf habe ich nicht geachtet."
"Nicht darüber nachgedacht."
Manchmal ist es etwas stressig.
Aber im positiven Sinne,
weil es herausfordernd ist.
Du musst immer
für deine Patienten da sein.
Lucas, guten Tag.
Grüezi.
Rose-Maries Familie
hat gerade von allem erfahren.
Sie wurde am Abend
ins Kantonsspital gebracht.
In der Nacht wurde sie zu uns
ins Trois-Chêne überführt.
Genau.
Jawohl, so ist es.
Ich habe sie vor 3 Std., also heute
um 7 Uhr, zum ersten Mal gesehen.
In so kurzer Zeit
kann ich nicht sagen,
ob sie wie vorher gehen kann
oder ob sie nach Hause kann.
Da kann ich mich
nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen.
Wir lassen ihr Zeit,
um wieder zu Kräften zu kommen,
und dann schauen wir,
wie es weitergeht.
Das ist bei jeder Person anders.
Nein, ich bin der Pfleger
und betreue die Patientin.
Klar.
Könnte ich noch Ihre Nummer haben,
damit wir Sie erreichen,
falls es nötig ist?
Ich schaue im Dossier,
welche Informationen wir haben.
Richtig.
Das ist so aufgeschrieben.
Gerne.
Ihnen auch. Auf Wiedersehen.
Sehr gut. Nicht sagen.
Aber? Keines. Ah, okay.
- Nein. Es gibt nichts zu sagen.
Du hast ihre Fragen beantwortet
und alles gut erklärt.
Hat dich das gestört?
- Nein, im Gegenteil.
Das hat geholfen.
- Tipptopp.
Ich hätte sonst nicht
an die Nummer gedacht.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Die Leute wollen wissen,
wie die Untersuchungen verliefen.
Aber wir dürfen keine Auskunft
geben. Das ist Arztsache.
Wir versuchen, die Leute
zu beruhigen und zu informieren,
soweit wir das als Pflegende dürfen.
Daran muss man sich halten.
Wenn jemand sehr besorgt ist,
verbindet man sie
mit dem Arzt oder der Ärztin,
der oder die zuständig ist
und die gewünschten Informationen
geben kann.
Lucas hat das cool gemacht. Super.
Ihre Tochter hat gerade angerufen.
Sie wollte wissen,
wie es Ihnen geht.
Haben Sie ihr gesagt,
dass ich Covid habe?- Ja.
Ihre Söhne wissen es auch und tun,
was zu tun ist.
Ist gut? Machen Sie sich
deswegen keine Sorgen.
Es ist auch niemand verärgert
oder wütend auf Sie.
Das ist doch auch beruhigend.
- Ja.
(Yamina)
Er kann es gut mit den Patienten.
Er kann sich in Menschen einfühlen.
Er hat einen guten Draht zum Team
und kommuniziert gut.
Das ist ein Vorteil.
Vieles lernt man nach und nach.
Ich lerne jetzt noch jeden Tag.
Lucas wird Rose-Marie
weiter betreuen,
um rauszufinden,
warum sie immer wieder stürzt,
und um das Covid zu überwachen.
Der Tag ist vorbei.
Aber bevor Lucas nach Hause geht,
macht er
die Übergabe an die Nachtschicht.
Ich denke, sie ist gestürzt,
weil sie sich
nirgends mehr halten konnte.
Sie hat Schmerzen in der Hüftgegend.
Sie hat Angst, sie habe
noch mehr Blutergüsse als vorher.
Sie hatte vorher schon viele.
Die Stürze beschäftigen sie.
Sie weiss,
dass sie das noch mehr einschränkt.
Jennifer übernimmt jetzt
Rose-Maries Betreuung.
Können wir Pause machen?
- Ja, ist gut. Alles klar.
Gibst du mir das bitte schnell?
* Entspannte Musik *
In dem Beruf
arbeiten ja auch 80 % Frauen.
Darauf muss man gefasst sein.
Mich stört das nicht.
Vielleicht
lasse ich mir die Haare wachsen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Lucas' Humor tut gut und erleichtert
den Start in die Nachtschicht.
Die Fröhlichkeit und Energie,
die junge Berufsleute mitbringen,
helfen allen beim Durchhalten.
In der nächsten Folge:
Bei Fanny muss es schnell gehen.
Wären da nur keine anderen Lenker.
Auch Hélène übt einen Notfall
und wird nervös.
Nervosität auch bei Lucas:
Wo sind die Venen?
Und bei Rebecca reiht sich
Nachtschicht an Nachtschicht.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022